chasse
c'est un prêt de
écoute c'est pas vrai ce que je te
contrôler ces composés que quand on sera
prêt ce que l'on va trouver du vent et
10 heures
autant on a senti qu'on vend pas c'est
là où ça va
forte d'un
parcours croisés à regarder
elle est propre
traiter
on est bien
on va pas attendu un on a rappelé tout
oui je pense que
c'est le brise glace pendant voyage
là bas
je prenais pas des choses
c'est qu'un jour de
l'accident
permet d'après match
c'est
seulement en entrant la seule à prendre
paul sartre ou les
fans de
vampires à 35
alors faire appel à un autre garde
le coup
c'est vraiment faire et voilà
à droite la plus large si la vie d'avant
bien trop seul bien la grappe en la
salle paul agon voilà voilà
contre eux
la route en plus de faire à ta droite
va pas trop se montrant pas trop tôt
hélas pas produit
je suis derrière balla balla balla balla
derrière avec la rencontre
voilà
j'ai envie de faire
le très talentueux on va voir
forcément on n'a pas le côté bleu
turquoise condamne alors
va remplir
tous pareils
vous contribuez on va voir
voilà un scoop mais un peu la plante
pareil maintenant on savait que ça sorte
que les horaires
du lun bref voilà pouvait rentrer très
peur après un cru de la planche
pourquoi
parlez
vous je tiens
notre second
parent
ces couleurs après le premier
soir
or
ce soir
apparu la soeur
reproduit le truc à la chine
les
rapports
les caribous reconnaître en la confiant
à la la la la
un message pense qu étalonner ça va
exploser parce que moi je regarde peu la
leçon que les images par la rva peu trop
vite
on est prêt la lazio et la gnac d'une
dose afin de voir j'ai beaucoup
travaillé leur idole d'enfance
on parle pas des enfants
on n'a pas trop
oh
ou presque
voir le la à l'espace jean guy tremblay
au
collège
en dessous verticale voilà
voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà on a coupé
la parole à
ces magnifiques heures
ce
sac à dos et à
la jambe droite et la droite
par
le passé
façon de réveiller tôt pour ses bons ils
vont partir un peu plus tôt
après la phase de travaux voilà j'essaie
de rester dans l'axé de la machine parce
que voilà peu plus après comparaison de
prix un peu en deçà
à la fois parce que là on avance à
la vitesse est pas là
à l'origine à la politique aux verts la
gauche un hangar de couleurs
pourquoi pas les locaux allaient bien
réglée à laval dernière
le
trottoir la
bande
pas pour autant à prévoir
voilà papa tu la sors balle à savoir la
toile
en fait on a fait le boulot si la noire
massive à
différentes
voix se fassent avoir
besoin
darcos
or quand à la barre puis
je pense que sur toutes les valeurs en
vue
elle a réservé et à revoir
la cnp temps malgré des
ratés en anglais et en français les
autres
la première
c'est de te piquer petercam l horizon là
dessus mais je pense que cinar sur la
terre pendant la rencontre en affaires
voilà l'une à droite
voir
j'ai malheureusement le mont cordon dans
l'ain
bravo tu auras peut voir
par contient des épaves savez on a le
coeur qui sont sera chez ici alors que
là il y en a eu que ce manque est pas
loin du cimetière et là à côté du lac au
pied du lac sevan normalement devant toi
tu devrais avoir une
varicelle d'avion on regarde la nage